okay logistic regression so now we're
going to get a little bit more mathy
let's for sure shorthand write p of x
for the probability that y is one given
x
and
and we're going to consider a simple
model a simple model for predicting
default yes or no using balance
one of the variables so a single
variable
so here's the form of logistic
regression
so that e is the is the
uh the scientific constant
the the exponential
value
and
we raise e to the to the power of a
linear model we've got a beta0 which is
the intercept and beta1 is the
coefficient of x
and
you see that appears in the numerator
and in the denominator but there's one
plus in the denominator
so
it's a somewhat complicated expression
but you can
you can
you can see straight away
that
the values have to lie between zero and
one
because
in the numerator e to anything is
positive
and
and then the new and the denominator is
bigger than the numerator
so it's always got to be bigger than
zero
and you can show that it's got to be
less than one when when beta0 plus beta
x gets very large this approaches 1. so
this is a special construct a
transformation of a linear model
to guarantee
that what we get out is a probability
so that's called the logistic regression
model
and actually the name logistic comes
from the transformation of this model so
this called a this is a monotone
transformation we take log of p of x
over one minus p of x
and out pops our linear model and that
transformation is called the log odds or
the logic transformation of the
probability
and this is the model that we're going
to talk about right now to summarize
we've got a linear model store
but it's modelling the probabilities on
a non-linear scale
and so back to our picture again there's
the
the picture on the right was produced by
a logistic regression model and and
that's why the probabilities lie between
zero and one
so
we've written down the model how do we
estimate the model from
from data
well the popular way is to use maximum
likelihood maximum likelihood was
introduced by huro
or me actually oh yes yes just last week
did you reinvent it or i didn't realize
it was actually yeah um
the correct answer is fisher back in the
1920s ronald fisher fisher
ronald fisher very famous statistician
invented a lot of the tools that we use
in in modern applied statistics and
maximum likelihood is one of them
well the way maximum likelihood works is
you've got a data series of observed
zeros and ones
and you've got a model for the
probabilities and that model involves
parameters in this case beta0 and beta
so for any values of the parameters we
can write down the probability of the
observed data
and since each observation is meant to
be independent of each other one
the probability of the observed data is
up is is is the probability of the
observed
string of zeros and ones
so wherever we observed a one we write
down the probability of a one which is p
of x so if x i if observation i was a
one
the probability is p of x i
and we write that down
and since they're all independent we
just multiply these probabilities and
these are the probabilities of a zero
which is one minus the probability of a
one
so this is the joint probability of the
observed sequence of zeros and ones
and of course it involves the parameters
and so the idea of maximum likelihood is
pick the parameters to make that
probability as large as possible because
after all you did observe the sequence
of zeros and ones
and so so that's the idea simple to say
not always simple to execute
but luckily we have programs that can do
this
and for example in in r we've got the
glm function
which in a in a snap of a finger will
fit this model for you and estimate the
parameters
and in this case this is what it
produced
the coefficient estimates were minus 10
for the intercept and .0055
for the slope for balance that's beta
and beta0
it also gives you this so they're the
coefficient estimates it also gives you
standard errors for each of the
coefficient estimates
it computes a z statistic and it also
gives you p values
oh i think that's realized something so
you had a picture a couple of slides ago
of
the a curve yes and is that how you
found the it was running how you found
the parameters for that curve is that
that's exactly right rob
so
this curve over here
is the curve corresponding to those
estimates that we just produced in the
table
and you might be surprised because the
slope is very small here
yet it it seemed to produce such a big
change in the probabilities
there may be a typo
i certainly hope not
but let's let's look a bit closer look
at the units of balance
they they in dollars right so we've got
two thousand dollars two thousand five
hundred dollars
and so
the the values of the coefficients which
are going to multiply that balance
variable
they they sort of take into account the
units that are used right
so this this is .005
per dollar
right but it would be five per thousand
dollars right so slopes you have to take
the units into account
and so the z-statistic which is a kind
of standardized slope does that and then
if we look at the p-value
we see that the
the
chance that actually this this balance
slope is zero is very small less than
.001 so both intercept and slopes
strongly significant in this case how do
i interpret that p value for the
intercept do i care about that or
we usually don't care so much about the
the p value for the intercept
the intercepts largely to do
with with the the preponderance of of
zeros and ones in the in the data set
and uh you know and that's
and so that's of less importance that's
just inherent in the data set that's the
slope that's really important
what do we do
with this model we can predict
probabilities
and so let's suppose we take a person
with a balance of a thousand dollars
well we can estimate their probabilities
so we just
plug in the thousand dollars into this
formula over here
and notice i've put hats on beta0 and
beta1 to indicate it that they've now
been estimated
from the data put a hat on the
probability
and here we've plugged in the numbers
and we use our calculator computer and
we get .006
so somebody with a balance of 1000
dollars
has a probability of .006 of defaulting
in other words pretty small
what if they've got a credit card
balance of two thousand dollars
that means they they owe two thousand
dollars rather than one thousand dollars
well if we go through the same procedure
now the probabilities jumped up to 0.586
so it's got much higher
and you can imagine if we put in three
thousand dollars would get even higher
let's do this again using
some of the other variables we haven't
seen student yet but one of our
predictors is student and it's a it's a
binary variable in this case it's a yes
or no variable is it is a is the
the credit card owner a student or not
and so we code that as a zero one
variable and we fit a simple logistic
regression model
and it gets a
coefficient of 0.4049
and that's also significant
okay let's do it again using
the variable student as a predictor this
is a
binary variable is the is the credit
card holder student or not
and we find we get a coefficient of
0.4049 in this case which is also
significant
so this is another variable in our
database and just like before we can
evaluate the probability of default
um
is yes given that the the cardholder is
a student it comes out to 0.4.04
and if they're not a student it comes
out to be a bit lower 0.029
close to 0.03
and we're going to examine the the
interactions between student and and
balance and other variables in a little
while